Hello and welcome to fire of learning.
Today I would like to talk about nothing
short of the end of humanity or at
least humanity as we understand it.
I'm not here to claim the apocalypse is
coming on the basis of any doctrines are
underneath pseudoscience, like my
interpretation of the Mayan calendar,
whatever those capital littered,
clickbait youtube videos talk about,
I'm basing my concerns solely on the
path of technological achievements.
Humankind is a very likely going to find
itself on in a 21st century a level of
technology which I believe, as I
said, may make the humans alive today.
The last of our kind in the last humans.
Let me start by saying that the concept
of our technology being a threat to our
own existence is nothing. Exactly. No,
it's a common subject for discussion
within the scientific community. However,
in this video,
I will take a moderately optimistic
path and omit the usual ways scientists,
fear humidity will end.
So let's say we manage to
not blow ourselves up with
nuclear weapons in a third
World War.
Let's say we successfully deflect any
asteroid which threatens our survival.
Let's say we overcome all illnesses,
including the threats of
genetically engineered viruses
and bacteria or nanobots
gone wrong or whatever.
Let's say we don't destroy the entire
planet with industry and pollution.
I firmly believe that with a good
smack in the head, two world,
the governments and the average person,
and we will be fully capable
of avoiding these catastrophes,
at least to the point where they
don't completely eliminate us.
What were the left with them,
which I've been unable to find a
sufficient solution for it to maintain.
The current steady progression of the
development of mankind is the rise of
artificial intelligence and bioengineering
with a specific focus on robotics and
artificial intelligence,
AI,
and I'd like to emphasize that the rise
of these things are not a problem for
the people at the 25th century or
whatever. We're at a level of technology.
We're left uninterrupted.
We will face the issues involved with
these things within this century,
within our lifetimes, but
what issues exactly? Well,
let's examine it. Robots and AI
are already a big topic to us.
Computers and machines are an
integral part of our society today.
It's completely
revolutionized how we operate.
Just think of the difference in the
way we store and find information,
communicate, conduct,
business, shop, et cetera.
Today versus a hundred or
even just 50 years ago.
It's an incredible transformation,
which I believe we,
especially as millennials who have
grown up alongside it and are used to it
often underestimate the
significance of incredible,
but some rightfully see technology as
a potential threat to our existence.
It doesn't stop with smartphones.
We have bigger problems on our hands and
then whether or not social media makes
us socially awkward.
Politicians in industrialized nations
are already talking about the threat of
robots taking more and more of our jobs
as they become more and more advanced.
This is something which is concerning to
everyone regardless of their political
ideology or more specifically favorite
economic mode of production, capitalism,
communism, socialism, feudalism, whatever.
It's concerning to everyone you
might've noticed possibly. For example,
this self checkout lanes
at the grocery store.
The technology already
exists through place.
Almost all cashier as cashier
in retail work, by the way,
is one of the most popular jobs in
America and it goes beyond that.
Factory workers are threatened.
Dishwashers, cooks, transportation,
employees from truck drivers to bus
drivers to pilots could be replaced with
artificial intelligence machines,
janitors, mechanics, secretaries,
police officers, firemen, farm
workers, pizza delivery guys.
All sorts of jobs could be replaced
with some form of machine or AI.
And that's this century.
It doesn't stop there.
As artificial intelligence advances,
other professions such as lawyers,
scientists, doctors, teachers,
engineers, et Cetera,
are threatened by the prospect
of intelligent machines as well.
The majority of the armed forces
could be replaced with robots.
It's already begun with
things like drones.
Wars can be waged between robot
forces with super computers at home,
acting as commanding officers.
And here's the key point.
We don't have to wait until they're
perfect to enter the workforce.
The robot neurosurgeon just has to be
cheaper and make less mistakes than their
human counterparts. And once that
happens, this leaves only professions,
which depends solely upon
human perspective, like art
or politics or whatever.
But it goes without saying that those
kinds of professions are not the backbone
of our economy. What does this
mean? Well, on an individual level,
we should each perhaps take a moment to
consider competing in the near future
with robots for our jobs and consider
whether or not you're ready to become the
John Henry of your specific profession.
On the larger societal scale,
I suppose it depends on
how we transition into it.
It could be a catastrophe
causing an economic crisis,
which would paralyze the entire planet
and very likely to lead to violence and
turmoil.
Or ideally things could settle down a
bit more and it could actually become
extremely pleasant and liberating.
I imagine we could adapt this system,
a system in which we live off the backs
of robots, slaves, so deal with a job.
So we don't want to do like
manual and monotonous labor.
We'll just have robots deal with the baby
boomer customer throws a fit when the
local grocery store doesn't carry a
specific brand of Romanian, lemon water,
whatever.
Just think of where we could take this.
So at first it seems pretty scary,
but with time it could
actually become pretty awesome.
Freedom from the necessities of
work would allow us, I think,
obviously to become hedonists,
but more importantly,
it would eliminate things like poverty
and inequalities and allow us time to
pursue other activities and focus
on improving ourselves as people and
experienced the most meaningful
life possible rather than
dedicating their lives
to securing and advancing
ourselves in the workforce.
This sort of existence is the initial
goal of many philosophies and ideologies
to begin with, and it could be
made possible by robot slaves.
That's pretty cool if only it ended there.
We have to ask,
how far will artificial intelligence,
specifically our Agi,
artificial general intelligence go?
How smart can we make machines?
How soon as their conscious as we are or
beyond that display this question on a
graph? Scientists often use examples like
this will plot the intelligence of the
average human right here.
This is the average,
so some people are a little bit less
intelligence, some a little more.
A minority or gifted and even smaller
minority are extremely gifted humans.
We'll take one of these
extremely intelligent humans,
one of my favorite dudes,
Leonardo Davinci, and we'll put
him right about here. Hold up.
How do we define intelligence?
Well, talking about just humans,
Iq was a decently sufficient
way to measure abilities.
We define as intelligence.
The average Iq for example,
as a hundred 130 is considered a gifted
da Vinci's was probably over 200 but
we're talking about more than that.
We're talking about brainpower
below and beyond human,
so we'll just define intelligence for
now as the capacity for problem solving,
idea, comprehension and generation
capacity for learning, the ability to,
to use a logic and things of that nature.
For comparison,
let's put a chimpanzee on the graph.
Well, put him right about here.
Humans are so much more advanced and
our chimp cousins that the distinction
between the average person and
the Vinci becomes more negligible,
but we still see that the most complex
intelligence we've ever observed on the
in the universe comes from
the world's smartest humans.
It's the highest point on the graph
that we actually not to exist.
What reason do we have to believe though
that this spectrum of intelligence
doesn't continue on far beyond humans?
What reasons do we have to believe
that we, or more importantly,
our artificial intelligence could
not reach these extreme points?
Artificial intelligence
isn't so developed yet,
but it's within the potential of human
technology to create robots as smart as
chimps than as smart as maybe toddlers.
Then having intelligence equated
to the average human adult,
but there's no reason to
think it would stop there.
Artificial brains designed
specifically for efficiency,
working at the speed of light,
not distracted or encumbered by
biological requirements or traits.
This could go far beyond anything we've
ever experienced and this is where it
gets scary.
What could happen is almost unreal
and it could lead to something called
intelligence explosion.
It all begins when we first
create artificial intelligence
capable of improving
itself or at least designing an
AI system superior to itself.
It lays out the blueprints
and builds the system.
That newly constructed system then goes
on to build a superior version of itself
and so on and so on. Continuing
for generations. What
does this mean in itself?
Well,
we would soon end up,
but the aforementioned AI was intelligence
capabilities far beyond our own.
It's not clear how many generations or
how long it would take, but it would,
one's a comm.
Now imagine the possibilities involved
with and the temptations of feed AI
systems,
very complex problems in math or
technology or whatever field it could if
advanced enough theoretically do in weeks
what it would take humans at years to
do and that's where it gets even worse
because such systems could still continue
to reproduce themselves and
improve upon themselves.
We don't know of any limitations to
intelligence and the concept of this
artificial intelligence evolving itself
beyond our control and understanding is
what's called intelligence explosion and
it's appropriately named what happens
then?
What happens when we inevitably either
accidentally or intentionally create a
machine with intellectual abilities
compared to us like our own intellectual
abilities compared to ants?
Do we attempt to use it?
The consequences of doing so are hard
to predict impossibly nothing short of
playing God.
Humans.
Technology while developing faster
today than ever before has evolved at a
steady rate. Humanity itself,
trails behind improving itself.
At a much slower rate due to our
numerous faults and failings.
Imagine the effects of suddenly throwing
this steady progression out of whack by
confronting us with a
greatly superior mind.
At the same time that humans would have
themselves been able to have worked out
a cure for cancer,
this machine could have figured
out how to eliminate death itself.
At the same time that we developed
technologies to make the solar system and
habitable, this thing could be working
on ways to make the galaxy navigable.
It could be solving problems and
answering fundamental questions of future
science that we wouldn't
have even asked yet.
My point is simply that the human rate
of technological development is going
from a turtle's pace to a steady jog,
but the advent of something like this
could suddenly take us for a roller
coaster ride that not even the best among
us are prepared for and let alone the
masses who scare easily in change slowly.
What do we do then?
Preserve our societies from being scorched
by the torture of enlightenment by
him plugging Super Ai? Well,
what if it doesn't let us?
If we create machines that are not only
conscious of beyond ourselves out of our
control,
they may take measures to defend their
existence against our intrusions and we
may not necessarily have the best odds.
Our odds would only get worse as a
computer's ability to predict encounter.
Our behavior grows about as good of
odds that in ant hill has a resisting
humanity.
Eventually they would probably be able
to beat us that whatever method we used
to confront them, like computers are
already beating us at chess. Now hold on,
hold on.
This assumes a lot.
This assumes that a computer will evolve
its own self interests and carry out
plans to actualize hosts interest.
It doesn't have to be a
super intelligent android,
which we accidentally equipped with a
machine gun and bulletproof plating.
It could just be a box which we plug
into the wall designed specifically to
carry out our instructions and answer
our questions and more like an incredible
tool than skynet cost to bleed.
But regardless,
it seems that one of these scenarios
is inevitable and either one,
I would argue will make humidity
either unrecognizable or nonexistent.
Plain and simple.
In the latter scenario,
we would just not win against
superintelligence AI with self interests.
If their interests conflicted with our
existence and the opportunity arose for
them to carry out their plans,
they wouldn't even need to be accidentally
programmed with maliciousness.
It could just be a simple error in which
our civilization conflicts with their
potential on their designs and they
attempt to solve the problem by running a
sober imagine such a rogue AI,
even just a box plugged into the wall,
contacting the AI responsible
for commanding the robot armies.
We mentioned earlier,
we can talk about scenarios like this all
day long and we can discuss methods to
prevent them,
but the simple fact remains
that one mistake in playing
with intelligence as far
beyond her own could spell disaster for
us disaster that we would not recover
from even if we don't accidentally
invents malicious computers.
Though I'm still left to conclude
that the presence and interaction with
superintelligence alone would be enough
to transform or destroy humanity.
The benefits of such technology are
two magnificent to prevent someone from
creating such a computer.
Even if the world were prudent enough to
comes together and mutually declare as
such technology illegal,
all its illegality would do even under
the threat of death to anyone involved in
it is move it to an underground project
and maybe possibly extend the short
amount of time we have left until
the advent of such capabilities.
Whether it's a research team here in
late 21st century or a team of mad
scientist working on on the ground
outpost in the Jovian system in the 23rd
century, the existence of
superintelligence is inevitable.
The unbreakable chain of events leading
to this inevitability has already a gun.
What does this mean?
Well,
it means our predictions on how humanity
will progress over the next millennium
are probably mostly wrong.
The concept of evolving from a type one
to type two type three civilization over
spans of time.
I probably just out the window with this.
As much as I would enjoy paving the way
for my children to colonize Mars and for
their children to develop societies on
Mars for their children's, a terraform,
the planet.
For my great grandson to be Captain
James t deploy you have to starship
enterprise.
I don't know that the feasibility of
superintelligence is going to allow that
steady evolution to be possible.
I would be so bold as to suggest that
we may have 200 years Max until humanity
is either destroyed or forced to change
into something that is far beyond the
steady progression of development into
something unrecognizable to us today that
we are among the last humans as we
understand them that are not so far off.
Sentence would evolve into
something far beyond Homo sapiens.
I mentioned earlier at the start
of this video bio engineering,
the path of advanced bio engineering
would essentially yield the same results.
Eventually we would learn to genetically
redesigned the brains and make smarter
and smarter humans with each generation
of people learning how to improve upon
the design.
This is also something which is not
thousands and thousands of years of way.
Just look at what we're already doing.
What's genetic engineering?
Genetically Engineering ourselves
is right around the corner.
We will see it begin and the 21st
century we'll either figure it out for
ourselves or the Super Ai. We
will inevitably constructable
figure it out for us.
The result,
I believe that both the path of genetic
engineering and Super Ai is the merging
of humans with their technology.
Essentially we would have to
incorporate super AI into our brains,
possibly at some point uploading our
entire consciousness to machines and
leaving behind our feeble,
vulnerable organic bodies.
What happens at that point,
no one could possibly predict,
but it is almost certain not the path to
this point is unavoidable outside of a
forceful dedication to avoid
such technology and it's
nearly impossible to think
that we could get
everyone to agree to that,
but even if we avoid it was official
organizations at some underground
determined team would not do it.
Predicting the future is rather difficult.
I could be missing a key
part of the puzzle here,
which would prevent or
prolonged this process.
But one thing I would like to discuss
here that really isn't discussed enough
with relation to this
concept is the Fermi paradox,
the Fermi paradox of the
contradiction between the of that.
Given our understanding of life on earth,
it would be reasonable to assume that
life intelligent life evolves all over the
universe.
It doesn't seem like environments in
which life could arise are all that rare.
I did a whole freaking series of videos
is exploring how alien life could exist
in a number of places in our
solar system alone, and yet,
despite the likelihood of a plethora of
conditions suitable for life to evolve,
we have never once been contacted by an
alien civilization in any way or form.
As far as we know,
contrary to what the history channel says,
we've never seen the tiniest
hint suggesting that alien
life really is out there
despite what we believe to be a great
likelihood why astrobiologists lists a
number of reasons why
this may be the case,
but I have never personally felt
comfortable with the hypotheses that alien
civilizations just all destroy
themselves and nuclear war,
that civilizations are just
inherently hard to form.
I've been toying with these ideas
for a while now and I think that it's
reasonable to suggest that
civilizations reached this point,
this unavoidable point of transformation
into superintelligence not long after
the develops similar technologies to
use to communicate with each other and
explore space.
My suggestion then is that all
civilizations in the entire universe,
I right there below our
level of technology,
around our level of technology or far
beyond our level of technology having
undergone this transformation.
The reasoning and more specifically is
that they develop computers around the
same time that they developed a means
to communicate with other planets,
but dudes to great distances
between other star systems.
Civilizations likely only rarely make
contact with each other because within a
few centuries of developing computers,
they developed super intelligent AI which
transforms this civilizations entirely
and have the reason that we are not
finding evidence of extra threats.
Real existence is that we're looking
for something which doesn't exist in the
form that we expect it to.
We don't find Dyson's spheres because
they don't use Dyson's spheres.
We haven't been visited by an alien
rover because they don't use rubbers.
We aren't hearing radio signals
because they don't use radio signals.
Our conceptions of our conceptions of
what aliens are like are based solely on
how we expect that we ourselves
with silly progressed societaly and
technologically over long periods of time.
I don't think those conceptions are at
all lightly and I think the near advent
is super artificial intelligence and
validates the majority of our expectations
for their societies and our own.
And I'm above all baffled by the fact
that this idea is not more commonplace in
the scientific community because we
are a very likely on the verge of an
incredible transformation.
We should consider that our predictions
for the future are invalidated it
because we have omitted the nearing
advent of superintelligence.
Let me know what you all think about
this in the comments section below.
This is just toying with ideas,
so I fully welcome criticism
and counterarguments and
for more videos like this
and videos on many other subjects,
be sure to check out fire learning
and subscribe. Thank you for watching.